what's up handsome Rambler listeners
this is Tony trim thanks for tuning in
the episode number 51 with Neal Brennan
co-creator of the Chappelle show he's
also got a new Netflix special out
called three mics it's really good I
highly recommend it really really good
stuff but anyways before we get this
episode started I just want to announce
some Hannibal some Hannibal tour dates
we got March 26 in Little Rock Arkansas
at revolution music room
March 27th in Memphis Tennessee at
mingle Woodhall March 28th we got a live
taping of the handsome Rambler podcast
at Third Man Records that's Jack White's
studio in Nashville they got a live
venue in there and we're gonna do a the
live podcast in there so come check us
out on March 28th and then March 29th
through March 31st we're gonna be
playing five shows in Nashville
Tennessee at Zanies
and then April 1st will be at in
Charlotte North Carolina
at the Morehead Street Tavern and then
on April 11th we'll be in Seattle at the
Neptune theatre and then we're gonna do
five more shows in Seattle from April
12th through the 14th at laughs comedy
club April 15th
we'll be in Portland Oregon at the
Keller auditorium May 9th and Mizzou
Missoula Montana at the Wilma May 10th
in Boise at the Knitting Factory May
11th and Spokane at the Knitting Factory
May 12th in Salt Lake City Utah at the
complex May 17th in Port Chester New
York at the Capitol Theatre May 18th
we'll be in Brooklyn at the Brooklyn
Academy of Music's Opera House May 19th
we'll be in Philly Myriam theatre so
yeah I think some of these are sold out
well I know some of these are sold out
but go to Hannibal Burres dot-com / tour
and get some tickets and come see us
I'll be there
Hannibal will be there and some special
guests so so hurry up and get your
tickets now at Hannibal Burres calm /
tour and enjoy the Tony
[Music]
and this really is a perfect
distillation of you your comedic boys I
really like it really I'm having spent
the last four days with you understand
your voice better than I've ever
understood it ha ha ha and what it is is
it's like it's organized scattered
scattered nests very inspired and really
like just my kits I couldn't predict
your I could not predict what you were
gonna say from a me and Hannibal just
did a show together like a TV show he's
around for three days we I wrote a pilot
for Comedy Central and it's a fake
Travel Show and the show is Hannibal and
it's a Hannibal shows me around Chicago
and then [ __ ] happens
but then but I would write like areas
for Hannibal and then he would attack
them and with a with with abandon and I
couldn't have predicted you said skeet
on feet never heard you use the term
skeet on feet which I was like I don't
know where the [ __ ] did I didn't know
how you thought of that before I think I
don't know I just was trying to say
creepy stuff yeah isn't up feet
I think maybe somebody else other people
just talk about [ __ ] with feet yeah I
think maybe yeah yeah and I think I just
found some creepy noises skeeto
you don't feel yeah great fantastic that
was that but it was nonlinear but right
on target which is beautiful hook clips
calm hook clip stop what is black and
Tony what would you say we were trying
to think of what the black pornhub is is
there by pornhub or you just black yeah
hook clips but it's like is going ghetto
Geiger's and there's some hood [ __ ] is
something with haters ghetto gangers car
it's a hood clip you know because at the
end they fight
a famous street fight at the end they
[ __ ] and then they go like what someone
breaks in then they have it that may
like have a then they spar yeah that was
fun though man yeah it was fun you were
very you were [ __ ] very funny and we
had a nice it became like a buddy movie
it was it was it was definitely weird it
was a fun shoot I hadn't I don't shoot
in Chicago yeah I shoot something maybe
once a year yeah maybe and it but so it
was fun to just be out in uh working in
those areas man you haven't done
anything on well we want division in
Laramie that's five minutes from where I
grew up is it really yeah the premise is
that Hannibal gets a mural dedicated to
him but it's he [ __ ] looks bad in it
and that's the mural but it was huge it
was like a huge scale it was a three
stories high on the side of a belly okay
and then we have to fix it
etc etc comedy ensues
Tony term what's with what's going on
with you man uh pretty much this this
has been my life just uh this company
mogh has just been sending me all kinds
of funky [ __ ] I think it's Moog it
smoked is it mo yes is it really yeah
everybody thinks it's move yeah I mean
that's what I mean that's how it's
spelled yeah why wouldn't you think that
Pannell smoke so they've been giving me
a lot of toys so I've just been in the
in the studio just busy you know me and
Hannibal were singing song on the show
yeah just freestylin somethin I mean yes
oh all right so basically I was chillin
yeah by the way on the way over here so
there's a white supremacist rally
somewhere in Oakland no oh now that
wouldn't [ __ ] bother with that oh but
they Arian Foster had a thing where he
said they're bars is trash so let's talk
about it real quick and see because they
were on some chanting [ __ ] they would
change they chanted but
[Music]
his nation terrible [ __ ] back again run
that terrible [ __ ] back say hearing it
reading it I was like that's not bad
though that's not a bad run but now
hearing it it didn't work at all it
sounds oh close borders white nation now
we start the deportation well that's
what you get when you've got white
people trying to write you know what I
mean
hot rhymes without some kind of
supervision you're gonna get just whack
[ __ ] that's what we have to look forward
to in the white nation deportation what
closed borders let's see if you can beat
it
should we try to beat it they want to
write for them write for them yeah
[Music]
to be great I know you've got a son and
a daughter but we're gonna close up or
no one anchor babies no and some babies
you wanna be me it's really dad to fun
poppy when I see these hypocrites up at
the country
well that's good man
I didn't realize that was in me regular
and they saw the rally wait a second oh
damn it and they started walking toward
it oh man yeah man yeah right there
mm-hmm but that's but again you're black
so you you're you're you can you can
write you can spit at a level that the
average white supremacist can't that's
what I would say yeah here he goes again
doesn't I need you to leave I need you
to do please leave you gotta go you
gotta go
USA there's nothing you could say except
like they want to keep you here you
gotta go I can't before I take this
framing clothing gotta go we don't want
you here no more you take job stole jobs
your lies your lies criminal let's get
out of here don't believe it no
subliminal babies there's no place for
that it was finally cut that out you
gotta leave personally the first run the
first round was like straight was he
hello did you write on all that I'm here
Lee I really didn't you yeah I wrote
okay what happened was I was writing for
singled out I wrote for the pilot for
singled out on MTV right this is nice
Chris Chris Hardwick was hard yeah and
Jenny McCarthy and Chris Hardwick
vennett they asked about a minute
goddamn yep
22 years and again deep yeah yeah and I
wrote for the the pilot of all that in
the office next door to us in that we
shared an office in like a common space
was the dudes from the sitcom head of
the class I don't know if you remember a
head of the class but it was uh Navy
Senate yeah
if became the British guy that was later
on it was these dudes Dan Dan Schneider
and Brian Robbins and they were starting
this kid sketch show and I pitched to
them I put some ideas they were like
you're not right for this year they
didn't hire me and then when they got
picked up the second season they brought
me in and that was like 1995 I guess
yeah and I wrote for uh five months
probably on all that season two which
some say is the best seat now I don't
know what they say historians will tell
me is the best year of all no but I was
not good at it and I did not get much
you know I did write
the Pierre escargots Kenan in the
bathtub that was mine the original yeah
the og yep okay
[Applause]
holiday French PA escargot escazu poovu
our free air on test dog rules air show
Merry Christmas may I get you a cup of
hot fat soon FAI Lotus Omar grandmère
that's nothing else that's my
grandmother
hey braggart
too cool sorry and I love a yes here
month we've Hey
look what the reindeer left on my roof
and and I wrote some some what was the
milkman some [ __ ]
was there a maybe what was maybe Cal had
a character I don't know uh something
with Turkey I don't know what the [ __ ]
was some allergy [ __ ]
and I wrote an ear boy that was pretty
hot and but they mostly would just make
fun of me in fact Bryan Robbins at one
point said I should have fired you when
I have the chance which is pretty
[ __ ] funny for a basta to say hey I
should have fired you is this no this is
during the show during they pick up my
option and then he jokingly not even but
not really jokingly because I wasn't
really getting anything out it said I
should have fired you when I had the
chance
yeah and dance and I used to throw [ __ ]
at me and he made us go to a gun range
at one point that's the only time you
know but he was just like who loved guns
the dude and he made us go to a gun
range to like in the middle of the
writing day which I was like I think I
hate this
the only never been no gun ranch did it
we did y'all go back to the room after
yeah yeah man did you feel more
productive I just felt like it was also
just shitty to like go from a gun range
to like writing kids sketch comedy
you don't know ray maybe he's trying to
create a dark vibe you know season was
violence
and but it was a good experience
Hannibal I'll tell you why maybe you can
relate to this I don't know if you care
about writing at all on TV shows but it
give it gave me a good like I would
think of something and not say it and
then somebody else would pitch it yeah
and get it I'd be like see I should just
say [ __ ] when I have that when I think
of it and that was like it gave me that
sort of like not common it's but it was
like gave me like okay I like if I'm
just think of the [ __ ] you just say that
[ __ ] you think of because in a writers
room we can get like you get shy or you
get like you get in your head like
you're not pitching enough yeah you got
to come with it you haven't said [ __ ]
that that dude got three ideas in a row
or and then I was like where I was
finally like a let me just pitch yeah
you gotta let it fly yeah exactly
even if it's not right in that form
somebody yes my it yes my yeah and like
we you know set it for the right you can
try to inspire someone else but like
this isn't the idea but here's the area
yeah maybe
do you get like some kind of a
commission if they use more of your
jokes do you get like let me throw you a
bonus or something nah on TV if you're
just on the staff like a lot of times if
you see like a sitcom be written by
so-and-so yeah but that just means they
wrote the first draft yeah the whole
room 15 people could rewrite it you
could end up having no jokes in it yeah
and but you get credit that a lot on The
Simpsons apparently where they'll
rewrite the [ __ ] out of everything to
the point where like whoever has credit
may not even have the most jokes on it
though they wanted the season finale of
30 rock yeah when I was there there was
a script that was group written just in
the room from scratch from page one
thrilled just in the room can I guess
you got credit for it yeah Tina Fey
Robert Carlock Hannibal Buress Oh - the
way the season finale alright 30 right
season five I think and I wasn't that
cool with it oh oh that's
because I think they drew in the room
and it was like and I maybe got a couple
jokes in it at that
were you not cool that's that's such a
comics way to think of it because I like
I was panicking I was like oh I talked
to another writer there was there volley
I was like yo man I ain't giving me
credit for this
I'm to really do [ __ ] on this and then
and I was did you feel guilty or you
felt like you didn't write weird yeah I
knew is a written by it is yes not even
close to him is not even yeah doctor you
know what I mean yeah so I didn't like
it that's interesting that happens a lot
on I did a pilot and it got picked up
but like I had nothing like and I get
money every time it sought yeah and I'm
like they reshot the pilot and I still
get money for every time they every
episode and I'm like mo guy I mean cool
but I don't I'm not like proud of it or
nothing it's just one of those like yeah
but do press around yeah the way you
connected the storylines in the season
finale first of all that was one of my
favorite episodes ever it was crazy I
mean just a tonne of it was bananas and
well you know it's when I thought of it
yeah cuz you can't explain to someone
like know it I had nothing to do with I
had nothing to do with it yeah that's
happen to me before it where it's like
yeah alright yeah I'll take credit but
like I don't really have [ __ ] to do with
it
[Music]
[Music]
snow
stop
yeah Chris did some savage [ __ ] last
night by the way Chris Rock were in
Oakland with Chris and they were talking
about I'm thinking about this because I
saw Chris do something gross which I
think I'm going to Instagram for
Halloween because it was his scare
everything which is plate of food plate
of Chris's dinner and then six inches
away he's clipping his own fingernails
[ __ ] wild [ __ ] and then sherrod small
his cousin said you think that's gross
you've never seen Chris blow his nose
with leaves like plain to me what like a
reason no like when they were kids like
football okay that would be funny of
Chris Rock still blew his nose with
leaves
it's like it's on his rider can I get a
box of leaves that's some no I mean I
see people do snot rock it's not like
regularly yeah but like that's fairly
like leaves to me is it night better
than snot rockets yeah but the
fingernails I found I mean it's his
dinner yeah so god bless yeah but still
it's like so weird
I saw your nails lose hair anything
around the food it's all Dean it's all
your business maybe you're strengthened
in your own human
maybe that's what part of one of his
secrets yeah one of his comedy secrets
he eats his own man yeah the nail-biting
thing going on they're all nails all the
time yeah yeah
LeBron eats his nails every game and
they show it which is a weird
do they still does he still do it uh-huh
when he goes to the bench in the third
quarter that was show I'm like yeah oh
but shout-out to Hannibal Buress also
for I we probably shouldn't say this on
the air but Hannibal Buress has broken
off his NBA streaming well yeah and be a
MBA a ba-leep pass I
do I have been given the password and
it's I've had a couple really great
night's game yeah check-in/check-out
yeah I watched the condense one last
night they can dance for a few minutes
15 minutes all the scoring that's it
yeah League pass you can it's all the
NBA games you pick and then you can
after the game is done you can pick and
convince condensed version and it just
shows the scoring and there's a 15
minutes they do that for baseball they
absolutely should I feel like I'm louder
than you guys is that I feel like you're
well no that's just that's I can always
fix it in post
oh you can't all right all right yeah
good my man but let the hannibal get
some ya know he hannibal gave me the
it's been great and which is which basic
missing meal why not just get your own
password is some other [ __ ]
that's what I've here's another thing
I've learned about Hannibal in the last
three days a cheap man not maybe per
capita per for the amount of money I
think you have your cheapness level is
[ __ ] impressive yeah really
like we're in an air B&B right now
animals doin shows with Chris Rock I
know the neighborhood of what he's
making Chris would have gotten him a
hotel he's probably giving you some
stipend for the hotel right off of me a
hotel and your and are you did you take
the money I'm getting money yes so you
taking the money I know how much the
rooms cost where we're staying right
Hannibal is making $100 a night profit
[Laughter]
and he gets a three bedroom Airbnb in
fact thank you for doing my pilot for
Comedy Central I'm gonna get you and I
wanted to present it on the air today
I'm giving you $1,000 Airbnb gifts
some gifts thousand dollars which for
Hannibal is gonna probably get you five
nights so it's my dad man my dad was I'm
not cheap like in a where's disgusting
way were you like that person doesn't
make sure to leave decent tips in places
yeah that type of thing but I don't want
to spend money where doesn't need to be
spent no matter the amount but then
sometimes I don't are you paranoid about
people writing if you don't tip like I
took a picture with Scottie Pippen on
Instagram a couple weeks ago and like
four different people wrote like no
tipping yeah like that's not the most
interesting thing about Scottie Pippen
like that's not that shouldn't be it
comes up a lot with his yeah that's just
that's unfortunate that arrived yeah but
are you D worried about like your rep
[Music]
was just where nightlife is pretty small
okay huh small world the club nightlife
nightlife and just the rest especially
if you go to places a lot it just makes
you smoother when you come back yeah
this is uh is this place in Chicago I go
to and we've done events there and you
know I've taken care of the bouncers
there what does that what just like if
we made some money and I took care of
the security for you know watching the
DJ booth or whatever tell me what that
means
give me talk right that's great but a
hundred dollars you can't argue with
well it might have been it might have
been couple but it was one night I was
back in
spot and I overhear this guy he say
something and if we having a
back-and-forth and then the security
they kind of see it happen and then you
know they start converging don't do
without he was it and then he started
the guy started saying some [ __ ] no
that's great it felt good and but I
don't think that happens without divot
yeah you're right yeah no that's
absolutely you're you're absolutely
right you were like became you became
like a drug lord
just by Mary sometimes people be on
[ __ ] yes yes yeah like yeah you got
to go yeah that is nice though like if
you do want a show when people are
making noise you like okay you know what
you got to go yeah and they just go what
[ __ ] you know you got it here's the
thing I can control that things I'm in
charge okay who gets to go and nobody
unless you would said some wild mean
[ __ ]
nobody's ever on the heckler sighs it's
such an easy tired these people
babysitters yeah now they are ostracized
by the way speaking of hecklers in this
pilot me and Hannibal went to that
hotdog place the Wiener circle and and
the woman whoever's like the main lady
the worst there yeah she [ __ ]
tourists [ __ ] on a level like it was
but I couldn't I reacted it she was so
funny doc we gotta have her own she is
so [ __ ] funny like not like with no
warning just in me saw Hannibal see you
saw she started roasting me she was at
the counter I'm out from outside on the
sidewalk literally 60 feet away
yeah giving me powder powder and it's
making she's like [ __ ] what you
gotta be kidding me
well you already black as coal and just
started yeah look at look at Forest
Whitaker look with his little eyes his
little eye [ __ ] back to the
[ __ ] races after that dot yeah
and so I get in there and she firing off
and I try to fire back a little bit
she's got the advantage because she a
works in a hot dog place so it's kind of
not for us to be like [ __ ] he you work
in a hot dog place like you know I mean
like we can't really hit her back yeah
but she was like just it was the speed
times I mean just like literally just
like you what you say you bowlegged and
knock kneed yeah I mean just like really
slick go funny [ __ ] like bang just
hitting a heart called me Benjamin
Button call me chicken little like said
I needed some insurer yeah to drink I
mean but then I felt like well we had
gotten all the footage we needed and he
was just kind of standing there and then
she just kept on run students and I was
like oh I think I think we need to get
out of here guys just kept on a [ __ ]
old couple can old come like 50 year old
fat white dude Asian lady she's like
look at Peter Griffin and mortgage show
just like she was going in yeah she
might have had a hot hand like
especially hot hand but she's like she's
[ __ ] funny like like she should go on
the road like not even like she could
for real she's funnier than most she's
funny she's better at that than maybe
anyone I've ever seen it was just really
fast
yeah it's this guy Don Theriot Don
Theriot Hudson is a guy from Chicago
where's my phone he's i and he just has
he has that type of style of roasting
yeah where he does that split screen
thing and when somebody working with a
weird look or a weird picture and then
he just uh he has his catchphrase and
then he just goes in roasting for and
he's just that's how he's built his
following but he has that same pace he's
a Chicago due to where Chicago [ __ ]
yep just they don't just yeah I got a
bake another one on baby 21 savage over
as frail as hell boy you must be ready
to attend this barbecue my brother yeah
barbecue boy ever like you walk around
saying sticks and stones may break my
bones but words will never hurt me
no if I [ __ ] through a wet piece
of rice at your bones you'll [ __ ] a
break your skinniest [ __ ] boy yeah he's
got a body full of catfish bones little
buddy lonely again asparagus later guys
neato and really gas Air Max 95
shoestring like a flamingo leg as he
only again rolled up bandy-legged
plastic button Ike Leggitt Yoshi like to
premature breadsticks from a piece of
her near Euler glands boy anorexic ant
looking at Rastafarian grasshopper
looking at honey i shrunk the penguin
looking at it's blowing baby boy
if Count Dracula was on the slimfast
diet looking at boy every time you go to
jail you get out the same hour cuz you
slide through the boss look ugly baby
matter of fact yo ass we're gonna
ancestry.com and got a DNA test and
found out you the third cousin to the
roaches old man in black yeah yeah I
just the Rivermen [ __ ] of it is so funny
to me yeah it feels like you have to
give you 30 jokes yeah and like he
doesn't judge them he doesn't know which
ones he doesn't care it's just like this
one that one I got this one you like
this how about that how about over here
looked out there over there like he
there's no like he doesn't it's just
they're all once it's just they're all
the same quality booty ass yeah that's
some I like that [ __ ]
I've respect I I like that
alright what else did I have on me and
Hannibal had some some not debates but
on the show that I'd like to bring
public which is a
how long do you think people wear pants
for meaning you put on a pair of pants
how many days you're gonna last how many
how many days if you're it's mostly guys
kiss girls where it's something depends
on what the the kind of pants Jade is
jeans jeans is a different story
jeans you can wear for like a month
straight the up for real you'd wear it
for a month straight without I mean
you're taking them off to sleep in -
[ __ ] yeah right
yeah and if well I might leave them on
to [ __ ] go what genes will denim man
like especially when you get a new denim
you got to break them shits in so like
denim doesn't stain well and breaking
denim in is denim in is a process so
I've owned a pair of like rod Dunham's
before I rocked it for like a week
straight cuz they went with everything
yeah oh yeah no I'll take it like six
days that's about that's about my limit
Hannibal what's your limit until some
bad happens think I spilled some sauce
on him huh you know I had to because I
went to DC last week before Chicago so
I've been home in like eight nine days
yeah and I had to get laundry done at
the hotel in Chicago
and I got alright I had like two shirts
dry-cleaned five pairs of underwear of
five pairs of socks and some pants
anyone want to guess how much that cost
three dollars it's a hundred eight
dollars and I was like I need [ __ ]
insurance hotel laundry get the [ __ ] out
of here
like how and I could I really had no
choice because I couldn't yeah like I
couldn't drop it off anywhere cuz I
didn't know like they would have been
collected hours we were working long
hours $108
I knew how finish man
Venice has a place to live yeah it's
great man they they opened Google and a
snapchat like their head not their
headquarters but they open offices so
it's just getting like it's getting like
cleaner and nicer and like the mites I'm
gonna make some money on this uh again
I'd sound like a [ __ ] [ __ ] but
got that place well I got the place like
seven years ago that's where we get the
first chance yeah we're the first champs
and and I got it like a seven years ago
and and now it's got to be they open
Google and snapchat basically like next
door I feel like but I don't really want
to move anyway yeah also don't you feel
like the world's gonna end like pretty
soon especially from that side from the
West yeah like I keep thinking like I
might make a profit on this house and
then I'm like [ __ ] where it's gonna
be over yeah but I don't know where to
go my god Jesus yeah between like you
know that's like Kansas you have via
head from either side yeah what's going
on in New York yeah yeah you know
Stanley Cooper go straight up yeah it's
manitoba stanley kubrick moved to
england because it was the furthest
place from like the Russia and the
United States in terms of nuclear
warheads Jesus like in the 60s or 70s
like he was like all right he was that
[ __ ] up about it
between that and global warming I'm like
what are the odds of [ __ ] last another
hundred fifty years the whole world I
mean I think the world as we know it is
over in about twenty Jesus that's dark
what do you think yeah but you know I
mean if they I'm so bit cuz I'm like in
the middle of my flyest years probably
right so I would have did what I wanted
[Music]
I've never liked the club like the club
the club yeah it's never been my meeting
it's always me ended up like standing in
the corner yeah
watching people give [ __ ] sparklies
on their champagne yeah
or their bottle services and then yeah
hot chicks yep douchey music yep douchey
[ __ ] yeah it's the club scene i've
never i've tried DJ clubs mica jacket I
could never immerse myself in that world
yeah these plates are the best if you
just work it like just go ahead and work
do yeah that's that's the [ __ ] but yeah
like when people like hey Hannibal
thanks for coming just wanted to tell
you anytime you're in town kabane just
like this I mean they did after-party
for us once where it wasn't even a like
they didn't even want us to spin through
nothing they were just like just come
and we're gonna give you money just
chill out
what spot was that I don't remember but
we did stay set up in Australia was it
Australia
yeah they set up a table we just all we
had to do was walk in sit down in the
VIP section and they paid us for it
that's great yeah god bless the club
they got money like that you got bottle
service you got money like that I mean
it's something you know that chick is
crazy when people get twenty thousand
fifty thousand dollars for a walkthrough
yeah yes the walk come through that's
Chris Rock was saying last night but he
used to DJ yeah like he was like a
really like a wax DJ like a vinyl DJ and
I was like you should start doing that
make some real macho that's all the same
thing previously on a handsome Rambla
podcast
I'm good friends with Prince Paul so and
whenever he spends in New York he lets
me know and I go and I'll spin for like
15 minutes
oh yes yeah people are like is that
Chris Rock amen there's a money on the
table for celebrity DJs I pick up I pick
up a couple grand here and there and I'm
not good at all I don't blame ya it's
seeing you up there Chris prices up
there play music that's though it's
people yes it's fun man but we bring the
theremin in and the idol tuned and we go
crazy we get weird over here man you
know this is uh you know
yeah can get an extra 50 if you wanted
to do it separately yeah it'd be crazy
yeah
kill it he could do a whole tour like
that yeah 100%
he can do 15 minutes to stand up and
then DJ I mean he wouldn't even yeah he
could make do what he does is DJ he
plays music and just talks [ __ ] on the
mic yeah is that what this is that's you
do the podcast is this but we're just
abrupt weird bliss [ __ ] yo do you still
do your internet cutoff productivity
time I remember it I used to yeah yeah
like the last couple years I've been
directing a lot of commercials and I
have to I have to just be on the
internet for this is constant notes yeah
like I just constantly got it like email
somebody or look at a thing or like so I
can't do it as much yeah but it is I do
it's still on my computer but i io
Virata
but it's a better you know what else
though you know what I realized is that
I'm in some ways I kind of need to
create like chaos in my head in order to
write jokes like if I'm like sort of
more if I'm more like inspired by like
internet articles and [ __ ] like all
that reading the New York Times and then
reading having a post and a little bit
of like Twitter and it's like it kind of
works for idea generation right like I
was I was kind of I was going on the
internet list but I think I was writing
less jokes if that makes sense because I
wasn't as inspired or aroused as it were
but I do recommend it to anybody who has
like I think it's it straight up in
addiction definitely yeah like the phone
and the haha and hit and refresh and
scrolling down and [ __ ] like it's a
it's a real problem and I love it
that's the thing is like I love I love
my like I love my father
like my phone is it so great like if
someone said no TV or no phone if you
like that TV it's like [ __ ] not even I
mean do you get like the dopamine when
you get the light like when people like
it you're like of course it's they
they've shown like they have straight of
rehab in Asia now oh yeah it like they
have straight-up rehab in South Korea
they have Internet rehab Wow and it's
come here to now like if you google it
it's they have it now in the States
I did a seven-day silent meditation
retreat like a year ago around here
actually it was in like north of uh
north of the bay and it was no no TV no
radio no phone no computer no writing no
reading whoa it was for like in no board
games nothing and it was why is talking
just no talking no totten silence
silence complete silence
yes but people yeah it was like try 40
other people so you guys talk to each
other like Apes no yeah no we wouldn't
talk at all we didn't invite around by
third but we would meditate all day and
by the third day the third day I think
we had like little round like we could
talk for two minutes about our
experience but at that point I was like
I don't even want to talk right so you
didn't I did I did but it was like
pretty brief like you felt what what I
realized is that all of this internet
[ __ ] it like it's it makes I like when I
used to smoke cigarettes and drink
coffee I would wake up in the morning
and like [ __ ] douse myself and coffee
and smoke like five cigarettes and like
almost shock myself and I do that now
with technology where it's like I get so
stimulated off of the [ __ ] that I like
sort of whined myself up and it's that's
that's it's not a natural state I think
the natural state is what I was in in
the in in the at the retreat this is the
unnatural state but it like you forget
because we're so surrounded by it do you
smoke weed now
see like I noticed because I smoke
occasionally now not I don't smoke like
I used to because I used to smoke like
every day like I was like a wake up and
talk all day all day every day but now I
do it occasionally and might do it I
noticed that I don't [ __ ] with my phone
at all when I'm high so it's almost like
I fear social media like yeah it took me
a while to get on the Twitter because
Twitter just felt so like like the Wild
West
it just it felt like you're exposing so
much and it just felt so like so
connected that I had a fear of it and
then when I'm high
like I get inside my head like I don't
want these people know my thoughts so
like I'd like to stay away from the
phone like it maybe we'd might help
maybe yeah I mean I don't that's the
thing is like I I got I think it works
do you don't I mean like there are
people that are addicted to heroin and
they can afford it but you couldn't like
we're all addicted to this [ __ ] but it's
a it's a entire society and culture
built around that addiction at this
point so I don't think it's like I'm
gonna I think I'm on the far end of it
like where I'm looking at my phone too
much but like yeah but I don't think
it's like I'm paying a price like right
still you have a job yeah I got a job I
got a but in that part of the job is
that and like making you know making
content and all that [ __ ] but uh but
yeah it's not I it's stimulating is
there is the no is the shitty part and
also you can accidentally change your
life and income through your phone yeah
there's just some weird video yeah you
think about that [ __ ] is bananas yeah
like yeah I don't know if you'd I don't
think you have but I think the
Internet's you're a viral dude like
you're a viral pickle juice went viral
that was like your first kind of [ __ ]
but I was thinking more just that you
know the Instagram oh yeah yeah you know
snapchat or how through this DJ Khaled
career he's made probably twenty five
million dollars off of
Instagram snapchat yeah yeah yes but yes
so in it what makes that so funny about
Callie
I remember watching this video a while
back of it was his birthday party and
Lil Wayne and a bunch of other people on
stage Rick Ross
t-pain a bunch of rappers on stage at
King of Diamonds and Khaled like Lil
Wayne is wrapping up there and Calot is
legit just right behind him just on his
phone yeah this is a few years ago yeah
you're that dude was weird
this is his birthday party Lil Wayne's
rap from right there and everyone I
remember sending it to people like look
at this [ __ ]
wife's birth and Assad I know the
[ __ ] son's name Assad from from like
it was the inlet in labor but it was
just so fun that was years ago seein any
damn he's I know I'm into my phone but I
think if little ways before Michael get
right they're like what do you do you
don't do the phone thing do you at your
shows know that the confiscate phones
thing no that's it is a do it though
yeah I tried it out and then uh yeah I
tried it once they hit me no expensive
right it's kind of expensive yeah you
can build into the ticket price or
whatever because I don't think is that
many it's a handful of people and
obviously I don't my [ __ ] doesn't have
the same intensity that rock or
Chappelle's yeah people will put their
whole [ __ ] online got whole sets online
from before you started doing it to do
it yeah that's people to have to do it
and put up signs and for the most part
people don't you can also get it removed
immediately right yeah and you just I
just have my web people they constantly
look for that and then shout-out to
Gracie in democracy shout-out to Gracie
the cleaner you know it's great though
is uh is this reminded me why
a lot but when I before I had the NBA
all access you could watch games live on
YouTube if you just hit like warriors
and then I'll use a filter live it'll
give you it'll show you a feed like you
can go on your computer I just put in
like streaming but if you go on reddit
or Google or yeah read it yeah it's
[ __ ] great I really like the internet
that's just--that's I mean this is kind
of a cul-de-sac of a conversation yeah
if you dig around few thing around on
the internet you could pretty much find
anything yeah anything
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what happened in the Portugal's soccer
game you you understand the childís joy
of a fake song like there's nothing more
childish than just making songs up just
being a noise band a noise band yeah
it's so great well I mean in
post-production I'll like put some stuff
together and try to do beats and make it
sound right but for the most part yeah
we're just like I mean I'm sure some of
you can't even get it there sometimes
yeah just keep it funky man yeah that's
a great funk rate that's great advice
doing doing don't don't don't don't
don't don't don't
no the three mics come out earlier this
year January January yeah it's very
brutally honest and good very honest
dear me
me uncomfortable couple times it's
supposed to I mean that's I don't its
post-its I was that was kind of the
ideas like what do i what do I not want
to talk about yeah let me talk about
that that seems like this yeah and like
it seems like you were doing like
self-therapy up there yeah but that's
also the thing of like and then everyone
think everyone comes up to me it's like
I have blank everyone relates to a
different part of it like I have
depression I'm hiding on my dad I mean
every single day on Instagram I get it
one or two messages like do you always
respond yeah for the most part as long
as it feels like you know how on
Instagram you'll get where you feel like
oh this is gonna be like a kitten
situation where like if I put out some
milk I'm gonna have to keep putting milk
out for this [ __ ] if I respond
to this person yeah this isn't gonna be
this isn't gonna be a one-off this isn't
gonna be like because you know there are
three questions away from like would you
watch my stand-up or would you how would
you let me hang out yeah can we and it's
like like were you just real where you
can like look at their page like now
they need this yeah I know exactly what
you're talking about well reply once or
twice and then I don't wanna I don't
want to keep this going yeah yeah and
you can tell that meant a lot to them
and you're like yeah I'm happy that it
meant a lot to you but like all right I
can't
I'm not we can't keep doing this if you
put a little milk out it's in Pootie
Tang there's the scene where he puts
milk out yeah and everyone comes to the
door it's probably my favorite scene in
Pootie Tang where women come and drink
milk from in front of booties door it's
a great [ __ ] scene no yeah but three
months came out and
was people were nice about it so like
it's [ __ ] Netflix has so many people
so a lot of people a lot of people have
Netflix and it's [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
they've taken over the comedy where all
it feels like no yeah it's not even
close I don't think anyone can even
compete took it over so much that the
Def Jam reunion was on Netflix HBO
franchise went to Netflix it would be
like the New York Knicks doing a tribute
to Michael Jordan by the way I there's a
I've got to give a shout out to an
Instagram account called Jumpman history
where they just have old footage of
Michael Jordan and it's all [ __ ]
amazing I'm gonna love that one it's so
great like it's so great they yesterday
they showed his second game in the NBA
and it's like he was bawling it was
crazy it's like he's it's almost like if
you just said like it was his all-time
highlights it was one game of the second
game in the NBA and if it was like if
that had been his only game it would
have been like a montage from anyone
else's whole career but this was just
one game my kids weren't good at
basketball I always say that you said
Michael Jordan is good at basketball
[Music]
gone insane
[Music]
and so Hannibal's been not drinking we
had a good time in Chicago Hannibal said
a lot of funny [ __ ] and not it was a
good time we shot in shy and we shot
quickly that was the other things fast
laughs how many locations was that the
first day the first day we must have
gone to eight places because I was
trying to I was texting somebody all the
place we went to and I forgot about like
the museum yeah when we went
river ride it's the museum of surgery it
was it was pretty [ __ ] interest oh I
think I know yeah Chicago historical
yeah the Chicago Historical Museum right
but it was yeah yeah yeah I know what
you're talk we went to the hotdog place
we in Hyde Park right sluggers no its
own logic make sure like fitting on it I
want the sluggers as long as we rode the
[ __ ] train by ourselves we like
commandeer to train which coming through
the L loggers is like douche bag Haven
yeah yeah I realized I had never been in
sluggers is this one of his some blocks
we as I've been in coming to this area
for goddamn 16 years I set and I've
never sat over block is just you know
what that is it's just a bunch of it's
all this it's all the suburban kids who
move into the city and turned a part of
the city into the suburbs yeah that's
what it is over there yeah it's
douchebag central like yeah standard I
go there to see the Cubs and the
seashells at the metro that's it yeah
oh man it's an awful neighborhood yeah
remember John Barleycorn it was this bar
called John Barleycorn couple floors
it's just I don't know what I was doing
back then I was going out a lot with
zero money just going out completely
broke and you would get in it was your
comments are displayed yeah just be
there and what do they have deals or
something sometimes I guess
you know you know you might have a
friend buy some drinks or something he's
just broke broke [ __ ]
I used the DJ at the spot called travia
uh-huh and so one night they shorted me
on my pay I think is something
ridiculous they paid me like twenty
dollars were spending for like four
hours and they had a downstairs bar but
they didn't open it that night because
it was like a Wednesday sound like
Hanuma let's go out there and [ __ ]
rob these fools so he went to the
downstairs bar he just cuffed as many
bottles he could like like grab the top
shelf [ __ ] let's get the [ __ ] out here
great then we just went back yeah went
back to the spot and was more liquor
than we could drink for a week this
thing after you guys try it graduated
from school this is yeah this is post
college yeah what you were you doing
stand-up at that point yeah it was that
was his Open Mic days and that was my
DJing for $20 and free beer days and
just straight-up just snitched on us
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they probably own a bar in Chicago they
got a long memory I remember we was sold
on the you know once if they wouldn't
you know what if they would have paid me
correctly
hey not none of this would have happened
business is business you got it yeah and
they that was well we took two bottles
or three no we took like four yeah it
took two babu's bottle of whiskey and
about from now you kept singing the Naza
lyric got you were like Grey Goose and a
whole lot of hydro right I like I like
on the nose yes situation absolutely
yo we you know is just some egos got and
wanted in line the rap stacks one you
met at the deli
yeah cuz we shoot this because the story
was shooting in had rap snack so I kept
on playing davon rats but they also have
a song was it called mother [ __ ]
tired that's the name of it mother
[ __ ] tired off of the album culture
and they got a long way say I just got a
burger from five guys
a turbo fire guy and you do that we
ordered and we ordered some five guys
when we were out at Coachella and I just
kept on playing that line over and over
yeah why wouldn't you I just got a
burger from five guys it just felt great
yeah great do you [ __ ] with festivals
right
yeah you just enjoy the whole scene I
just I mean is a before I enjoy doing my
show and then being ABS go chill and
watch it it's nice to be able to do
stand-up and then not have to watch
stand-up yeah and just like it's a [ __ ]
yeah watch all type is this fun you get
to see I mean I enjoy getting just cuz
you know how we travel to get to see
people we don't normally see yeah so but
this year we got I personally thought
festival out we didn't maybe six festive
we did six festival but then I went to
like four because my friends just
randomly have like VIP pass yeah you
can't turn that down yeah
Lollapalooza stand standing next to
Anthony Rizzo and Obama's daughter just
you know like you can who's Anthony
Rizzo Cubs play all right yeah
[Music]
get me drunk throw my eyes in the crowd
to get the blackened man
switched up my rapping style a friend
you Jesse McIntyre
go to the strip - Becca's happy smacking
thighs
yupi attract the last
this my rapper skies
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes yeah yeah Brennan on the terror man
this [ __ ] is smoking like the tendons of
a Nancy Kerrigan I get the delivery
right on that but the written on a
tariff and this [ __ ] is coming like the
citizen needs to care again and need
some syllables out hold up come on down
his life
Brennan on a theremin dish it is
spinning like the tendons of Nancy
Kerrigan today I cut my hair again I cut
it every week I'm a black dude I gotta
have a fresh cut in the streets now I
get scruffy vampire your mom's Buffy I'm
a senior but yo yo yep yo I'm glad to
see your mom's of flavor alone yeah
Lama is that you my flavor love kissing
you and I'm out in front of cameras I
really can't up as bad as will sell with
his hair a television you it's in other
women was trying to get a different
flavor
yep
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
[Music]
imagine imagine imagine
if your mom was
eliminating
save it
what is that reality
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah now if Elvis [ __ ] bro that's one of
the most cohesive sessions we've had is
that true yeah no worries my camera I
got in the pocket yeah you were you were
I was laughing as hard if you want to
see me laugh if anyone ever needs
footage of me laughing really hard when
you started talking about Nancy Kerrigan
I felt X I felt pure ecstasy and I
thought if we this would be some kind of
life if we were to figure this out
yeah and become a like a real outfit and
go on the road
yeah and just do nonsense I'm trying to
figure out how to how to figure this out
for television trying to figure out how
to you know what I mean as a as like its
own show yeah just that second segment
know the whole podcast I want to convert
it into television show alright let's
let's talk this out
TV loves segments that's what Eric Andre
that's what Eric Andre is them the
probably that most Dada
[ __ ] abstract Bing bong show of all
time yeah yeah I love that show too but
and the reason it's it works is because
it feels like whatever you whatever
sequence you're in is not gonna last
more than 40 seconds true and then you
can do the freeze and that dude yeah and
then you're under the next one if you
figured out a way to do those I mean you
would almost if you had directions for
the songs that would help if it was just
like people wrote in and people need a
song about whatever right and then you
could take it from there and I want I
want Hannibal on the theremin and
thought of to make me laugh so hard
there was just a real that's my favorite
[ __ ] in the world is what we just did
that level of nonsense that's really
like any girlfriend I've ever had will
tell you like oh and editor Beach on the
beach on about it especially on a bunch
of other [ __ ] knows
I love nonsense yeah and I mean I think
we're all on the same page here yeah so
if you figure out a way to do with that
I think our cameras are dead no it's all
good the cameras dead that's what I said
we'll never can we don't need no cameras
did you see this bonus footage issue
just this and then you're gonna get it
on your foot get it did it
well then walking down the street over
in Oakland you trying to kick that's a
tough beat to catch but I want to try to
catch it you can do yeah who d DB DD DB
do it it went up into the street went up
into the cupboard
grabbed everything I need put it all in
the oven I'm burning all over my supply
now they bout to be a song about burning
up everything from the pantry to the
oven put it from the pantry to the hay
from the pantry
set out from the pan
so grab it put the [ __ ] freakin in the
oven what you say don't go do it go
where I put it put it up in then turn it
to foam on it spread it for freaking
[ __ ] spell allspice
the plastic is melting the [ __ ] isn't
that nice leaving Belton and it's burnt
the [ __ ] is done now it's my turn
go back to the cover gotta find
something else to put up in the oven
let's go with the pepper with the pepper
cause and the grinder say don't put it
in there where this pass to come from
looks like made in China
no man and still move in the top you say
the burn peppery I'm supposed to put it
on something not gonna put it in the
oven straight burning pepper burning
down a city sauce smelly
now sneezing up in the kitchen cuz the
pepper fumes got the tripartite then
shouldn't I put some pepper in
got a little boom grab a bass fans my
gas mask that's a bit too much I grabbed
one of those fast and everybody where
they live intubated get it's light
enough not enough material but it gets
the job done
puts off the desert that you conjure it
up
yeah man you [ __ ] serve it you give
it out well I mean this party has got to
come to an end
yeah man yeah man you like as a fan of
the clips of the show yeah
it was and I would always think the [ __ ]
is when is Hannibal gonna bless me with
an appearance I feel like I feel like
this I mean I'm a little under the
weather so you'll have to forgive me but
uh but I feel like I'm really strangely
proud of the fact that we had one of
what you considered one of the better
one that was one of the most cohesive oh
yeah yeah that feels good oh yeah you
you you felt it you caught it yeah with
it it was the hand with the Nancy
Kerrigan's hit mm-hmm yeah and written
on it there and burn it up like a
tendons of Nancy Kerrigan
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
mrs. Davis East
I'm Nancy Kerrigan absences services
basic arrogate of celibacy step assist
sorry
Nancy Kerrigan my apologies I'm so sorry
b-but that much rhymes with bread
Santa's Nancy Kerrigan like a makeup oh
you got a respectful a fancy degree
without
[Music]
that's my rap crunch I go back to that
like a false start
you got a mouse heart
[Music]
yeah Thank You Brendan yeah that was
awesome
[Music]